herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute ich bin hier in österreich ich bin
am ziel bin ist mein leib aber trotzdem
kommen natürlich ein video für euch denn
das ist der februar in den jeden
verdammten tag ein video kommt ist dass
der offizielle name wollen wir herrscht
februar in dem an ihren taten video
kommt machen glaube es wahrscheinlich so
gut und für das heutige video habe ich
diesen ice cream braun am start den kann
man nämlich einfach nur um rollen
nachdem ein paar sachen eingefügt hat
und dann entsteht durch das herumrollen
eis themen wie man essen kann
das will ich euch mal mit euch testen
also dann packen wir das gute stück mann
aus jetzt läuft irgendwie 40 euro oder
sowas gekostet weil über sondern er ist
auch echt schwer und ich bin mal
gespannt ob sich das lohnt welt ist muss
schon recht gut sein also es muss
mindestens so gut sein wie normales ich
glaube so weiß cremig maschinen das
kriegt man auch schon günstiger drehen
wir das mal auf die eine seite
da ist glaube ich die seite in die saane
und was sonst so zum lifestyle zum
speiseeis teil gehört reinkommen zu
einfach so ein aluminium behälter und da
passt schon ordentlich was rein also ich
weiß nicht ob mir das voll machen kann
wir werden gleich mal auch nicht was
rein für unsere arbeit auch lohnt auf
der rückseite ist noch eine weitere
öffnung die öffentlich ist auch einfach
mal vertreten sie auf genau und da seht
ihr schon wenn er mal reinschaut mit
einer kamera
darin sieht man quasi diese
aluminiumkapseln wurden der anderen
seite und außen rum kommt dann hat das
eis und sonst wie das leitbild einer
möglichst großen oberfläche die kälte
übertragen
sicherlich fragt ihr euch auch die
funktioniert denn das herumreisen zeit
und zwar aus irgendwelchen magischen
gründen wird sei es zusammen mit den
kühl also ich weiss nicht genau welche
temperaturen erreicht werden aber auf
jeden fall deutlich in die minusgrade -
und dass man dann wirklich richtigkeit
und habe mich auch schon in die
häufig videos sehen gemerkt ich bin ein
sehr belesener mann dass man zum
beispiel getränke wieder schnell gehen
kann indem man die probezeit mit crushed
ice zusammen tut aber reden wir nicht so
lange herum getesten jetzt einfach mal
ob das ganze funktioniert als erstes
kommt die sahne und so weiter ein
so klingt als bevor es hieß es wir
machen ein doppeltes paket rein weil das
wird dann aber kein süßes so die zweite
folgen wenn der zucker sein kann auf ein
schaut jetzt einfach mal kurz vor sieht
das aktuelle aus ist einfach nicht
besonders aber tätig gespannt ob noch
was glückliches wirklich verwirrt dass
jetzt einfach mal so ein bisschen und
dann befinden wir die andere seite
das riecht jetzt schon wie man ihr leid
also wir haben quasi schon mal die halbe
miete geschafft so einfach andere seite
auftreten
wir sind einmal die eine packung seid
jetzt komplett rhein alles ganz grobes
salz das ist wichtig für die kühnheit
maximierung des produktes hallo lassen
aber das funktioniert also da und hat
noch das cluster für das macht doch ohne
wir sind nämlich bei ja in der
ferienwohnung hier deshalb schadet
kleine empfehlung macht das nicht am
tisch sondern
draußen oder würde mach dir und ganze
und gibt so natürlich macht das jetzt zu
und drews einmal komplett ist es schon
mehr als schwer genug war an dem wir
jetzt mal raus geholt göppinger firma
das panorama das ist echt nach vorne die
berge
es ist zu tun
klingt nicht so kobi scheiße man jetzt
das vorgehen das heißt wir holen jetzt
ein paar leute fragt nicht ob ich das
noch mal verlängern
irgendwie ist schön gekracht aufwendig
dass man so 20 gehen kann braucht man
muss das alles sehr lecker sein aber wir
schauen wir mal ob der fall überhaupt
noch da eine minute ist vergangen
hochwertiger observierte und hat sich
nichts getan wir arbeiten auch weiter
brennen jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt
bemerkt haben dass hier abonnieren
solltet
[Musik]
wie gemacht so läuft jetzt schon so
zählt er beides komplett dreckig machen
wir mal ob sie etwas getan hat dass wir
vielleicht noch mal neues eis und seiten
ist das schon eins kann man dabei schon
vom ansprechen sagt 40 oder wir führen
jetzt noch mal ein bisschen salz und eis
machen das jetzt einfach mal komplett
vielleicht dass gerade auch nicht
gereicht aber ich würde sagen es hat
auch schon ein bisschen was ich getan an
der konsistenz vom eis weil von der
saane
okay das jetzt ist das buch ist toll und
wir wollten wir ein bisschen rum
[Musik]
so leute werden das jetzt wirklich ihr
seht ja wohl dunkel geworden wir haben
es locker 20 minuten gemacht weil ich
eröffne mal schauen wir mal rein gefühlt
ist es weniger geworden und nehmen jetzt
aber mal den löffel den ich immer nur
einer jackentasche habe und wir gucken
mal
guck mal hier rein ich gehe mal mit dem
löffel ganz an den bol ihr seht das
jetzt schon ich habe doch warte mal ich
jetzt erste akt wird das eis ist
wahrscheinlich an den wänden ich sagte
jetzt die ganze zeit das hätte nicht
funktioniert aber ich hab's mal hier
anwenden da ist das eis und ich dachte
das hätte nicht funktioniert der ist nur
noch so wenig drin waren den ganzen
wenden das eis ist okay ich probiere
jetzt mein erstes selbst gemacht das
heißt alter hut ist es voll geil das ist
also das ist ohne witz wahrscheinlich
dass cremiges eis was ich jemals
gegessen habe
das ist einfach cool als mein erstes
selbst gemacht das heißt können das ist
so krass cremig oder was sagst du wir
haben also noch ein bisschen für sich
finden bisschen süße das ist ja ich
wollte es warnt jetzt so ein bisschen so
macht mein ansatz war ja das ist so
therapeutisch nervt ist so begehrt dass
er sich bewegen und dann ist da noch
nicht so süß machen und habe ist mir das
alles raus gut ist immer noch mega viel
drin brei das einfach total ergiebig ist
wie ein 2 1 gemacht jetzt haben wir
schon mega viel reis aber die sache ist
es ist glaube ich zu kalt geworden weil
das verhält sich nicht wie normale size
wir haben es einfach zu lange gemacht
weil wir dachten ja das funktioniert
nicht wie haben die uns auch einmal in
die bedienungsanleitung geschaut und
haben geguckt dass man eigentlich nach
zehn minuten rum werfen den äußeren rand
abkratzen mussten das manchmal
vermischen muss aber auf der verpackung
außenstelle 20
unsere außen gesteuert ich würde sagen
wir warten des teams das ein bisschen
eis jäger wird und dann probiert man
vieles fazit ob es sich lohnt oder nicht
so wie er mich so ein bisschen gewartet
dass es immer noch bombenfest glaube das
kann man auf jeden fall optimieren das
war jetzt der erste versucht man hätte
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zucker rein
machen können und irgendwie kann man das
rezept noch immer verbessern deshalb es
jetzt einfach mal auf meinem macbook
hier ein bisschen von meinem
selbstgemachten eis aber davor müssen
natürlich noch die schokostreusel rein
für die maximale gönnen
das habe ich ein echter dient also wenn
man schon eis ist aus diesem weiter hat
man sich wirklich verdient mit
schokostreuseln megageil das hätte man
schon so sahne obendrauf gemacht aber
sie sahen es drin schaut so dabei nur
auf diese hilfe von hilfen damit nicht
an aber nicht gut wenn ihr wollt dass
sich das irgendwie mal im sommer in xxl
machte es gibt da verschiedene versionen
und verschiedene sorten einfach oder so
13 wir sehen uns dann mal nächsten video
morgen wieder dance ist der februar
anteile und bis dahin macht's gut